>> So remember, this was the data set from the general population distribution.
Now let's find the standard deviation of our sample of social networkers, and
compare it to this standard deviation. Notice how when we did this, we were very
organized. We found the mean, we found the deviations from mean, we squared each
deviation, we took the average And then we took the square root, to get the
standard deviation. So finally, find the standard deviation, of this sample, of
size 10, and of people with the social network. We're going to ignore Mark
Zuckerberg, he's no longer part of our sample. I recommend you organize it like
we did before, where you have a column of the deviations, and a column of the
squared deviations. This is going to take you awhile, especially because it's
probably your first time calculating the standard deviation by hand. So take
your time, because the important thing is that you really understand how to do
it, and what it is. And when you're done, put your answer here.